Taylor and Bono have you worked together
no not yet we're going to talk about it
later okay okay but Bono you did a very
nice thing when Taylor got to Ireland
I've been I'm Swifty
now we're we're highly um aerial Birds
you know and over the years we come you
know we've bumped into each other I mean
he doesn't he doesn't want to take
credit for the fact that he's so nice he
sent me roses when I played in Dublin
yep
roses you know they're really great
person yeah
[Applause]
beautiful and he's just that great and
thoughtful just the best there is I
better have a drink
we're the tailoring Eddie you have
worked together we have oh wow yeah it
was a decade ago I once died in his arms
in a screen test for Les Mis no I did
not know this I did not know this yeah
there's a lot that people don't know
about this story
um basically I was I was auditioning for
two roles in Les Mis and I'd done a few
auditions and gone to New York and
whatever and I think it had been
established that I I had more of a look
of cozette but I had the range vocally
of eponine so it was established that
like I was there for a good time not a
long time
I wasn't gonna get this role but they
were like you know do you want to come
to London for one last green test and
you'll get to screen test with Eddie
Redman I'm like this seems like an
experience I want to have in my life
you're like one of my favorite actors
you're so ridiculously talented
I was like so yeah I'll go to London
I get there and they're like okay so we
really want to like make you look like
eponine we're gonna try to do it's the
you know she she did she wasn't like
loaded she had Brown teeth you know like
she didn't have a lot of money so a 19th
century Street yeah
say it in a way
it didn't floss exactly they were like
we're actually going to paint your teeth
Brown for this and I'm like so you're
gonna do that after I meet Eddie
Redmayne right that's
that's not something you do
I get to meet people and then you do the
brown teeth like no no it's um this is
just everybody's gonna meet you with the
brown teeth we're gonna we're gonna like
do like big circles under your eyes like
like you're near death and
I was like this this has immediately
become a nightmare for me
um and so then I had you know we you
were so nice but I think when I met you
I was like
it was hilarious I you know as you
walked in as a 19th century French
street urchin and and and I was not
expecting that but my overwhelming
memory that Taylor was I had
um I'd just been to Pizza Express
beforehand and I'd had some some garlic
dough balls
I thought we were going to be singing
off with each other you know that but
they they had us also it was so weird
because Taylor was dressed fully as
eponine and I was like in my tracksuit
and they had us on the floor like
singing Sweet Nothings into each other
and all I knew is I just had garlic
bread
Brown teeth
one of these it's like trying to show
emotions
and I just thought it was because of how
I looked
so but like I have to be close to her
right now this is yeah this was not the
method no no
everyone starts somewhere we've got a
very early gig of of Taylor uh this is
you now you haven't sold out oh yeah
[Applause]
do you remember this yeah this was a big
deal for me I was 14. and it was an
event called the Nashville rubber duck
race and it is exactly as it sounds they
would put rubber ducks in the river wow
and uh see who won wow and I was the
official entertainment as you can see
the banner is incredibly High concept
it just says it like it is you know like
this is her name did you play before the
race or after the race oh you know what
that's a really good question I think I
blocked a lot of this out okay I won't
dwell it might be triggering I was the
whole crowd the whole crowded I should
see three people back yeah they do look
like fans of rubber duck racing
Alex when they were kids dreaming of
being uh singers you were a kid but am I
right that when you got spotted you
didn't particularly want to be a
footballer no I used to play in a
football cage at the end of my road with
the boys and then there was a referee in
the local area was like there's a
women's team Arsenal I really want to
take you down I was like no I'm totally
fine my mama packed me a cat for a son
for a pack lunch that day I was like I'm
totally fine in this football cage and
she was like no we are taking you and
then I got signed to Arsenal when I was
eight yeah
there was concrete it was just nothing
in there but for me it was everything is
where all the dreams started literally
you had cars either side of this
football cage and if the ball went out
the car would come along and pop it and
that would be the end of play time that
like but I'll see you tomorrow they
should introduce that into professional
football I love that thing against a car
my friends are so jealous that I'm
getting to meet you because we just look
at you as such an inspiration like
breaking through in such a male
dominated industry you should be so
proud of it
[Applause]
and we see that over here and we're like
that is it how incredible is that so we
know you've always been behind
supporting other women and leading the
way so thank you
[Applause]
you talked about swifties and and how
much they love you and and fans
sometimes find on unlikely uh things
like I think in Canada by accident uh a
track from 1989 was released but it
wasn't a real trade was it eight seconds
of static yes this happened
um maybe seven or eight years ago yeah
what happened to that track that was
eight seconds of static it went number
one
um I don't I don't know how but maybe
it's some metaphor some symbolism about
the Sounds of Silence
having a moment of quiet I love someone
trying to present a chart show in Canada
going and now it's number one is it was
ridiculous I don't know I mean I didn't
I don't know how that I don't know why
I'm this lucky and have them doing stuff
like that for me
swifties and I think there are some here
so I was 50 to choice because Taylor's
new album Midnight it's out now yes it
is
Robin here now there are different ones
aren't there different ones yeah so I've
asked which one have I got I've got the
main version of it uh oh yeah yeah
that's the that's the standard version
It's a concept album and the main
question is what keeps you up at night
so it's you know you could be up at
night because you're reeling from just
having met someone and you're falling
for them or you could be plotting
Revenge you could be uh garlic
yeah you could be thinking about the
time that they they painted your teeth
Browns
um you could be you could be thinking
about what could have been you know
there's just so many possibilities if
you give that like if you think of that
as like a creative writing prompt which
is what I did that's where the album
came from and this album couldn't have
only I mean amazing reviews you broke
streaming records and a lot of the rave
reviews have asked the question and it
is a question that the great songwriting
on this album is part of it due to the
fact that you've been doing this sort of
strange work of re-recording your back
catalog so it was like you were doing
homework on songwriting I think so I
really do I've been so I've been
re-recording uh my first six albums
because there was a thing that happened
where I had wanted to own my work of my
first six albums and I when I changed
record labels my first six albums were
actually sold
away from me
um and so I decided to just I just
figured if I if I made them the first
time I can make them again I love it I
love it
amazing moment
but yes yeah but but tell me this is it
working like our radio stations playing
the Taylor version yes they've actually
there's actually one of the things I was
most thankful for was there's a there's
a company of many stations in America
called I heart and they have uh sworn to
only play my new versions and they've
said that they'll switch it out for the
old versions uh every time I put out a
new version of a song which is just like
it's so heartwarming to me because this
is something that I care about but I
don't expect other people to care about
it it's something that's very personal
to me and it's a lot of work but it's
like it's it's really fun and rewarding
for me and I can't believe people have
actually gotten behind it the way they
have and doing this you know going back
over your old work has led to this
wonderful thing where so all too well uh
as now I know
it's now it's now a short film yes so it
was a short song then it was a longer
song and now it's a short film
how do I shorten this so basically all
too well was a song that came out
originally on an album called red which
came out in 2012. I always loved this
song it was never a single but the fans
really loved this song and I had made
the mistake of saying in an interview
the truth which is that it had started
out as a 10 minute song with like six or
seven extra verses and and we had had to
cut it down to the sort of four and a
half five minute length that it ended up
my fans were would not let it go they
were like I'd be doing an interview for
something else albums later and they'd
be like where's the 10-minute version
where is it
um so basically for the re-record I was
like I am going to put out the 10 minute
version I'm just gonna I'm just gonna
show them what it was and you know what
I really want to make I want to tell a
story that goes along with it visually
that's that's more than a music video I
wanna I'd been I'd been directing my
music videos for a while at this point
and writing and directing them was
really fun for me
I just love it it's a very natural
extension of my storytelling so I
thought I'll make I want to make a short
film and and really do this song Justice
and also create a short film that stands
on its own so I was very lucky to be
able to cast Sadie sink and Dylan
O'Brien to be these two young lovers and
um and I'm just I'm really really really
proud of it
[Music]